vamos a calcular la raíz quinta de 32 y
como siempre pausa el vídeo e intenta
ver si tú puedes encontrar la respuesta
bien primero vamos a recordar lo que
significa tomar la raíz quinta si
tenemos que x es igual a la raíz quinta
de 32 esto es exactamente lo mismo que
decir que x elevado a la quinta potencia
es igual a 32 así que tenemos que
encontrar un cierto número tal que es lo
multiplicas por sí mismo cinco veces
obtengas 32 y bueno hay varias formas de
aproximarnos sobre todo cuando tenemos
este tipo de raíces con números muy
grandes como en este caso la raíz quinta
de 32 una forma es intentar factorizar a
32 y ver si existen factores que
aparezcan cinco veces bueno 32 puedes
reconocer que es un número par y por lo
tanto es divisible entre 2 así que 32 es
2 por 16 16 es 2 por 8
es 2 por 4 y 42 por 2 y bueno en este
caso usando la técnica de factorización
encontramos ya la respuesta porque
puedes ver que 32 es lo mismo que 2 por
2 por 2 por 2 por 2 o 2 elevado a la
quinta es decir puedes escribir como la
raíz quinta de 2 elevado a la quinta lo
cual va a ser de una manera clara
simplemente 22 elevado la quinta es 32
bien hagamos otro más pero este va a ser
un poquito más difícil de imaginar que
queremos ahora tomarnos de la raíz
quinta de 243 y ahora tengo un número
mucho más grande así que bueno ya vimos
que hay un par de formas para
encontrarla la primera fue factor y
shandong pero ahora tenemos número más
grande así que tal vez sea un poco más
difícil pero la otra forma es sólo un
poco de prueba de ensayo y error así que
para hacer esto sin calculadora para
encontrar sin calculadora raíces de
números muy grandes y más raíces como
esta que parece un poco complicada lo
que te recomiendo es que intentes
factorizar y ver que puedes encontrar
así que si usamos la técnica de
factorización
primero 243 no es divisible entre 2
entonces vamos a probar si es divisible
con 3 y seguramente estás familiarizado
con la técnica de cómo saber si un
número es divisible entre 3
si sumas todos sus dígitos y la suma de
los dígitos es divisible entre 3
entonces el número original será
divisible entre 3 bien ahora vamos a
fijarnos en la suma de los dígitos que
es la suma de dos más 4 + 3 lo cual es 9
y 9 es divisible entre 3 y por lo tanto
243 es divisible entre 3 entonces esto
va a ser bueno 243 entre 3 es 81
entonces me quedarían 3 por 81 81
también es divisible entre 3 lo cual es
3 por 27 así que creo que ya ves por
dónde va este ejercicio 3 por 27 y 27
como ya sabes también es divisible entre
3 es 3 por 9 y 9 3 por 3 y seguramente
ya sabes a dónde vamos porque si factor
izamos esto vamos a poder ver que la
raíz quinta de 243
3 ahora otra forma en la que pudiste
encontrar la respuesta es con mera
prueba de ensayo y error
ya sabemos que uno elevado a la quinta
es 1 también ya sabemos que 2 elevado la
quinta es 32 eso lo acabamos de ver y
ahora ya sabemos que tres elevado la
quinta es 243 pero imagina que no
sabemos cuánto estrés elevado en la
quinta por ejemplo si queremos saber
cuántos 4 elevado a la quinta eso lo
puedo hacer aquí tengo 4 x 4 x 4 x 4 x 4
4 x 4 es 16 16 x 4 64 64 x 4 es 256 y
256 x 4 es 1024 y bueno esto es porque
alguna vez lo hice a mano así que ya
sabemos cuántos 4 elevado a la quinta y
si ahora queremos la raíz quinta de 243
entonces dirás bueno qué número elevado
a la quinta potencia es 243 y si tienes
la idea de que es una solución entera ya
sabes algo que sea 2
o algo entonces tres parece ser un buen
candidato si la solución tuviera
decimales en definitiva sería más
complicado pero bueno es una buena forma
de intentar con tres y cuando lo
intentas muy genial
obtienes 243